he got in a stance he was ready to come
off the line of scrimmage and uh mcloven
was a defensive back there you were
Jason seahorn he just smashed you with a
pie stop with the seahorn stuff like is
is Marshall and the guys on TV we have
made seahorn greater later than he
actually was in reality let's stop with
that Madness seahorn shuts you down stop
with that madness he did all the things
in the world Jason seahorn he shut you
down you you there a lot of people man
there a lot of people you could have
picked out that really gave me some
battles I don't know why we talk I had
to have a defensive back how many white
quarterbacks Mike I don't it's not a
long list here hey okay you're right I
got you like Larry Wilson or somebody
Scott case he got some Scott case in him
well Scott wasn't a cornerback though
Scott I play a little corner he had some
Corner ability but he was safy Scott
knocked me out Scott Scott Hit me hard
as but about as hard as I've ever been
here him and vincey Glenn that's my dude
I saw Scott a couple weeks ago man and
he's still a good dude man but he he
looks a little like Scott case I would
give him Scott case he would like to be
Scott case now does it boother this
Jason seahorn thing bothers you this
thing is growing legs man why but okay
who's bringing it up other than I just
use it as a reference point as a
defensive but no on our show every week
Marshall brings it up Marshall f i
brings it up every week man I was like
listen man but you know why he brings it
up because of this reaction right yes
exactly then stop reacting this
way stop telling lies tell the truth I
mean you guys can't JC was a good was a
good corner but this is what happened
could do that isn't this the story
though you didn't know that he was white
when you played against him is that the
story no no I know I I I knew jc1 was uh
white white I knew he was there story
and he was a good player now he was a
good player but I I guys I I I beat up
on guys like Deion Sanders D green W
Woodson W all these guys happen to have
gold jackets and then you guys throwing
up Jason seahorn not that he was there's
a lot of there's there's always a Hall
of Fame pitcher who has problems with a
guy who wasn't a great hitter the one
guy the one guy my one guy was Robert
Massie I'll give you that it was Robert
Massie Robert M I I could come off 160
on Daryl green and have three for 38
against Robert Massie for some reason
with the Saints you know and the only
reason Massie gave me problems is
because I I when he was in college I I
built a relationship with him to help um
Drew rosenhouse get his first client and
and I gave him too many of my secets
that was the only guy that I went into a
game and I would say I had problems with
everybody else I beat him down except
for seahorn seahorn owned you but you
know see what I'm saying thing here PA
let's bring in Jason
seahorn hey I love SE he's my man he's
my man he good good Michael Irvin the
Hall of Famer he's uh he's here in the
man cave in the man cave what do you
think of this man cave I I I know listen
I I like this inside setup I I I love
when I first came in the first thing I
noticed was you got 88 on as a guest I
see that I like that then I had to go to
bathroom you have Newton and Manzel and
I was like Newton or Manzel let me try
Newton you
know do you guys kind of take a pick and
see who goes in the what bathroom yeah
the most no but one's a one Jersey and
one's a two Jersey right I know but but
but but different people in in both in
some situations so I just took the
Newton anyway you went Cam Newton
bathroom yeah yeah I went Cam Newton
bathroom over to Manzel opportunity and
I love Manzel That's my boy now I talked
to Johnny but since we both have had
issues I thought we need to split up you
know what I'm saying when's the last
time you talked Manzel uh probably a
couple couple a couple couple weeks ago
almost two months ago probably yeah
Johnny's good man he a good man want to
play football of course he wants to play
I I he he wants to play he'll say he
wants to play but you know wanting to
and and and getting all your Ducks lined
up in a row are two different things a
lot of people want to do things but what
it takes to do it sometimes is a little
more difficult I don't know if it's a
top priority for
him yeah I I I I I just just doesn't
feel like that you you had to make a
decision you had to balance what you
were doing with your life you had to
have that come to Jesus moment where you
said if I go this way I may go all the
way this way or I can go this way to the
hall of fame yeah but but but listen and
he's not talented enough to be what you
were well here too now my issue my
issues really came about after I was a
star in the NFL Johnny's issues is it
came about before he was even really
playing in the NFL so so two different
things in that perspective you know what
I mean so I I I know Johnny wanted to
play in the league and I was hoping he
playing leag I love stories like Johnny
Manzel and guys that have had issues and
come back and fight back and I pull for
those guys so I hope he gets an
opportunity and come back and show
everybody it's a great inspirational
motivational something I can use moving
forward talking with people if he could
do it what if Jerry Jones reached out to
him what about it bring him in as a
backup quarterback yeah yeah I wanted
that before I don't know that I
necessarily want it now you know we have
a young guy and we got we we we we're
set pretty good right there in the youth
category we don't need to add more youth
to the but Jerry did love him during the
draft smart guy Jerry like anybody to
keep the Dallas Cowboys on the lips of
everybody explain to me the Tony Romo
situation of of how this plays out
because we don't there's no resolution
here we're still waiting for right Tony
Romo to find out what he's doing with
his life but but it's it's smart what
they're doing right now I don't know why
they even announced that they were going
to relase relas him when they did I I
mean I'd imagine you know when I talked
to Jerry uh last week talked to Jerry
last week and I and I called well he
called me and we were talking for a
moment and I I said hey tell me about
our boy he
said Tony no no no no Jerry no no no I
don't even want to hear about Tony don't
say a word about Tony tell me about Zeke
I don't tell me about Zeke what's going
on with Zeke I I the Tony thing man I I
don't want to I'm not a reporter I don't
want to report it I'll just talk about
it after it happens but but I don't know
why Jerry would say anything at first
when when you hold all the cars just
wait just wait Tony's a big piece for a
team like Houston team like Denver that
can really get them over the top
somebody's going to make a move and this
I don't know why Houston won't throw up
something throw out anything you threw
72 million to bark oswal and that didn't
work so you can't just throw up a few
draft picks and say Jerry take this
right now I don't understand that how
nervous would you be if your Jerry and
Tony Romo goes to Houston I I want to be
nervous
Texas dude listen never in your lifetime
my lifetime and your kids lifetime will
the Houston Texans take over Texas from
the Dallas Cowboys never don't even
sweat it don't worry about it I think
people when they say that I don't think
that has me what if who has a better
chance of winning the Super Bowl if Tony
Romo went to
Houston I still think Dallas have better
chance win the Super Bowl and who cares
if they're playing in the Super Bowl
then that that'll be something and I
still would take Dallas in that game and
winning that Super Bowl why why why why
would it be a problem I just throw it
out there Mike oh that's what you do
that's I just thought all I do is like
John Stockton you're Malone on the fast
break that's all it is well can can we
be somebody that won the championships
as I want wow wow yeah yeah yeah not I I
like stock in them alone but they
delivered just not a ring
well who else do you who else can I be I
mean I I didn't win a championship
either so I'm sort of stocked in but I
got enough for both of us be so we can
be we can be we can be I can I can blown
you a few my rings so let's be somebody
that want some rings you don't have your
rings on today right no no no I I don't
wear that's only Super Bowl time right I
I don't I I don't ever I don't ever wear
those those are ugly no yeah they're
ugly I don't I don't it's hard to callar
them these are Super Bowl rings you
don't call them ugly
these are God's good but God's brother
that's that's cool Brothers like God I
can take God I want you to see my ring
that's okay but ugly they don't need to
see it you played it you want it you
don't you don't need to show a ring no I
don't I don't but when you win one ring
you do Montana's not wearing his cuz cuz
Joe W enough he's like me when you win
enough you don't need to wear them if
you just win one you got remind people
you won you have to right right but you
know you win one wear it and show it all
the time if you win as many as I have
they know you have them as many as
Montana has he you know you have them
best quarterback of all
time Tom Brady period because he has
more Rings he has more rings and he's
done it in a different time in a
different era with group different
groups of guys and getting the same
results it's no doubt in my mind he he's
the best he's the greatest of all time
and I know a lot of you guys don't like
that a lot of people don't like it
because they like to Horn in on all of
this the flake gate and all that bull Ma
and all that junk but the reality is
what it is the man is the greatest and
when you put air in the balls or when
you took away the Spock cam whatever you
say he was doing he still keeps whooping
t t your butt so let it go people Let It
Go who would you rather have you throw
passes
to what do you mean they Brady is your
quarterback or Montana Aman's off the
board okay I thank you see Troy you're
off the board Troy because because you
weren't gon to pick Troy you were still
G to pick Brady or Montana no no no I
was going to pick Troy why would I pick
somebody outside of Troy you're not
gonna pick the greatest quarterback of
all time no no he's the greatest
quarterback of all time for his system
Troy was the greatest in my system and I
played best in that system I got you
can't get me in that Dan I'm G see Troy
next week you can't get me in that one
throwing you the ball bro
Montana I I I either either one but I I
would hear still say brady Brady's a bad
man man Brad man I love Jo Mo I love him
when I see him I love but but boy Don
Brady is is Joe Brady has done it with
different groups of guys with different
skill sets within that group you know uh
uh Joe had his guys and and and speaking
of that God bless Dwight Clark and saw
that news yeah yeah I saw him I was with
him I saw him I was with him man let me
I since he announced it now I can share
it uh I was with him last week week and
a half ago and he and he shared it with
me that he had LS and everything and man
it was like my God you know it was it
was hard news but one thing I'll say
this man he says his guy you know his
owner his man has called him almost
every day every day to make sure he's
okay see if he needs anything I was like
boy that that's great man cuz I said
that see that's what great see he and I
we have the same kind of owners you know
we play for the same kind of owners and
and I just love that man so I'm praying
I'm praying for Dwight Clark former
Niner great yeah Dwight Clark announced
that uh he has ALS yes so all right
we'll come back with Michael irant we'll
uh dip into the deep end uh with terl
Owens with the Hall of Fame is he
helping himself or hurting himself here
well it's a good conversation we shall
have that conversation I I I I talked to
to about a week and a half ago right
hold on this called a tease I know I got
it so when you go to break you give him
a tease that's the tease that I talked
to him a week and a half ago so Michael
talked to Tio a week and a half ago
about the same topic we'll find out what
that conversation was all about right
after this here on the damn Patrick Show
she's got a new movie It's called slamma
jamama yes sir it's out next Friday
that's March 24th you play an attorney
that would be Friday Friday that that
would be Friday this Friday yes March
24th yeah you say next this next Friday
okay we haven't got to this Friday but
it comes out March 20th okay so you play
an attorney
Mike you've been around enough you you
know I love you D I love you D you were
just drawn upon previous situations here
you play an attorney defense attorney
I'm assuming well I play an agent I play
an agent Oh I thought you play an
attorney well an agent well I'm an
attorney in there I you know I I did get
uh law lessons of the law I I paid a
healthy price for that lesson in the law
so so I I I do get a chance to put it to
use here in this movie and it's it's
it's a movie
about uh Chris Staples who who's the
main character in the movie A guy that
plays basketball and he gets in a
situation and goes to prison and he gets
out of prison and tries to put it all
back together so it's a movie about
Redemption which which is really at home
for me you know anything that involves
Sports and then talks about Redemption
and reviv and one life giv another
opportunity that's my world so I I
really enjoyed doing the movie who else
is in the movie well for people you
would know like joseo comes by in the
movie I I thought that was fascinating
that you know guys like me him guys that
have had
issues are in this movie with the kid
speaking to him about issues so I I said
you know in this movie I said this would
be great I should do this I won't have
to go and study with anybody do any
method acting I I live this world right
here so it worked out really good it it
was a fun time to shoot the movie shot
in La being around those kids man I'm G
tell you something Dan them dudes are
phenomenal dunking basketballs it's
amazing what they do dunking their
basketball how high they jump you know
look guy p he's 5et nothing and can get
up and Dunkle basketball like that it
really is an amazing
gift and we're all lucky to have had
that gift no no no you don't have that
gift well not
anymore D you ain't you never had that D
did you have you ever dunked yeah I'm
talking about a regulation siiz goal
absolutely without a trampoline anything
absolutely oh really not even yeah it's
not even it's I'm I'm I'm going to be
I'm I'm being straight with you here
that you've never done I I will swear on
but I won't swear on my children but I
would swear on anything else but if it's
I'll swear not swear on your children
well I don't want to do that I swear on
the Bible how about that yeah I'm gonna
go with JC on
you yeah now what do you got to say I'm
going big man I'm going JC got I got
that's that's something my brother like
do man I I swear you on my mama my daddy
grave my M all right I got a couple
already gone what does it make all right
let me I got to let me bring this up
Terell Owens didn't get in the Hall of
Fame yes is he helping or hurting
himself for next year with the Hall of
Fame how he's lobbying logic would say
he's not helping himself logic would say
that if if what we're talking about
everybody saying his numbers are what
they are and he should be in on the
numbers alone and and I do believe that
and they're saying there's other reasons
that he's not in because of the way he
was with teams and things like that and
now you're spewing the same things at
some of the the uh the the voters then
then you would say he's not helping
himself but that's logic and this thing
is all illogical it's not all about
logic and you just never know I I talk
with too should he be in the Hall of
Fame oh absolutely okay no doubt let's
let's just stop the mess right now yes
he should be in Hall of Fame and I and I
talk with him and uh a couple weeks ago
we were shooting a commercial he and I
in LA and then and and we that's when I
found out he had this little jacket I
don't know if you have you guys seen
jacket with the number with h of Fame
jacket yeah he had the jacket with him
and I said Tio he was telling me about
it I said don't do that I said don't no
no you shouldn't do that you shouldn't
do it just just let it play I said to
him guys I said listen let us fight for
you right now you have everybody
fighting for you but if you jump in the
fight you no longer are the victim and
people turn on you just just stay out
and D Man and honestly said he said you
know it doesn't matter to him anymore if
he didn't get in on the first years it
does matter but but this this is what I
said to him Dan and and and and and I
said Tio listen man I said you're
fighting for the wrong thing the fight
is not you against the writers the fight
is for you to for for you be in to be in
the hall and have your great grand kids
and family walk through there and get a
sister of Pride that knows what what is
the Hall of Fame is also in them you're
fighting for what's coming after you
don't fight what's in front of you fight
for what's coming after you and and and
you know I I keep telling him that
that's what I think his focus should be
on but he can't change this is who he's
always been so to ask him to all of a
sudden look at it differently because I
was hoping he'd just say it's
unfortunate I hope they do their
research and I get a chance for next
year well let's break that back down Dan
on he can't change everybody changes
because because everybody we hope do you
think he but has he changed we grow can
he change yes you get you here you m
yeah this is all I'm talking about yeah
I know he's gonna fight it how does it
make it sound if I say yes and he's
fighting it like it is what do I what do
I look like right here but but but you
know and and after that right I I get a
phone call from Chris Myers from Gary
Myers he he's asking me about too and I
said to him the same thing I say to you
guys just then about Tio you're fighting
for what's coming after you and he wrote
something and Tio called me week later
hey man what you say I just told you the
same thing I said to you in the when we
were shooting the commercial you know
and so it feels like f with all of it it
feels like they're now they're going
back and looking at the number of drops
he's had it feels like they're changing
the rules he got to the two yard line
and now they've sent him back to the 15
ydd line and I it it's it's unfortunate
because he's a whole Famer I don't think
they're looking at him the same way they
have other players well let's be real
here now it it's been difficult for a
lot of receivers in in this on this walk
I mean AR monk waited forever and he
when he retired he was top of the league
across the board with championship rings
you know and they still made him wait
forever so it's just something that they
do with wide receivers sometimes you
know but they made you wait they made
you wait because of off the field not on
the field well and and I but is that
fair it it's well listen why why fair is
one word just is another they may think
in their mind it's fair I I will say
it's not just because the rules say that
is not what you're supposed to take into
account yeah just like the to situation
so in trying to show me or teach too or
show someone uh or teach them a lesson
you're really breaking the rules
and you're being a hypocrite you're
being a hypocrite like we're mad at you
for breaking the rules so we're going to
break the rules on you it makes no sense
whatsoever he's Michael Irvin the
playmaker of the movie coming out this
next Friday March 24th it's called see
Slama Jama you don't want to be wrong uh
we found uh we found Tom Brady's jerseys
they uh were found in Mexico EO sources
close to me tell me they were found in
Mexico so you had the the credentialed
me member of the media who took Brady's
jersey from the Seattle Super bow and
then came back for second helpings in
Houston and now they tracked him down
you know anything else about this yeah I
don't I I tell you what I do know just
if you got away with the crime the first
time don't return to the scene and
commit the same crime do you think that
Jersey's worth $500,000 I I think so now
yes I I didn't think so then but I
certainly think so now because all of
the stuff that is added to it this
jersey has been everywhere and and now
even the one that you know you put these
things together you put two of those
those two jerseys together you get a
million dollars for him here's another
question I have for you and this came up
during the season with somebody with the
Cowboys affiliated with the Cowboys who
said you know they never worry about Dak
Prescott they they like who he is they
worry about Ezekiel Elliott off the
field now the worry was not you know is
he committing crimes or anything it's
just being enjoying who he is impulsive
impulsive uh how concerned would you be
about Ezekiel Elliot off the field well
I here again I I don't think as they are
say and I believe so too I don't think
he's going to do anything criminally you
know where where he's out committing
crimes or anything but but you know
young man and impulsive and a lot of
things around him I can see where you
should have some concerns there I mean
he I've been right there right there
where he is I know the trappings that
come around but you
and just the and that's what I'm saying
the understanding and awareness of
what's going on around you you know like
the other day you knew he had to know
somebody shooting that you had to know
that not that you should do it in the
dark but you're under investigation Mike
you're under investigation with the NFL
yeah yeah and and and and and
that's it was horrific that it let's
let's let's stop it you know plenty guys
I plenty guys it was just a bad deal all
around it was a bad deal all around but
did you when you watch it though I'm
watching it and every time I see it
right I watch it now and I'm like I can
see the wheel spinning in his head like
should I so I said don't do it don't do
even now I keep saying don't do it like
it'll change it's not going to change
every time I look at it he's going to
grab and and and he just shouldn't do it
all one more thing here and that's Colin
Kaepernick um
is somebody going to give him a chance
here uh Spike Lee came out the filmmaker
and said something's fishy that nobody's
given him a chance my point is what's
fishy the fact that nobody's given him a
chance
now I I'm going to read into this a
little more with what [__] Lee saying
yeah that is Colin Kaepernick being
black what happened during the anthem
like that he's being blackballed that
I'm going to read into it he's he's left
it open to interpretation there um and
my point is Colin Kaepernick put himself
in the his position he took a stand or
um he just didn't play well right I I I
got to factor that in if if Kaepernick
had just played in the Super Bowl and
was on the free market people are going
to take him if he didn't stand for the
anthem and you're not taking him now
because I don't think he's proven
himself to be good enough to take uh
post post post uh Harbaugh leaving yeah
right you know let's be real and and you
have to be a specific type of a coach
that knows how to get the best out of
him think
got well I I I don't know that I can say
he's being black ball I mean he
just he was just on the football field
at the end of the season last season so
so you know when you start saying
someone's being black ball let me see
him go a good year a year and a half
without anybody picking him up then you
start looking at that and saying wow but
at the end of the season he was playing
football so it's it's hard to say he's
being black ball right now but I do say
that we know how important it is to find
a quarterback we know the value of
quarterback in this league so so so for
somebody to not give him an opportunity
that is eyebrow raising eyebrow raising
you you rais an eyebrow to that enough
but I don't think he's I can't go far to
say he's black ball right now so the
Jets Browns needing a
quarterback they need a lot of things
and and and they don't need other things
that don't bring about wins on the
football field and those are the things
that are coming with
that's just the reality of it so you
can't get on the Jets and the Browns or
those type of teams because they are
already down in the gut and then they
bring in stuff that puts them farther
down in the gut they they're trying to
get out of that rut and and change and
turn things around and I understand that
too the movie comes out this next Friday
it's called Slammer jamama Michael irin
will be in there killing it yeah killing
it killing it having fun uh thanks for
coming in thanks for going out of your
way this was worth it that pie face I
need me some shots of that for my social
media that was worth it all man I would
do anything I wish I could d d can I do
that to you one day when when do you
ever get a pie in the face does Dan ever
get a pie in the face uh I have I had
one in Houston and uh in our celebrity
bracket challenge for March Madness the
worst bracket gets a pie of the face so
I I I didn't ask you that I said have
you ever gotten that p face not just in
Houston right here at home you got right
in this room right in this place if you
you take the Cowboys to win the Super
Bowl if they win the Super Bowl you can
hit me in the face with a pie again I
ask you I've not had a pie the face this
is how the lawyers taught me to keep
coming back to the question but wait I'm
this is my huddle I'm Troy Amman right
now and that's the pron right there I
knew you never got the pie in the face
cuz this whole building is your huddle
and as everybody else gets the pie in
the face and Dan say it's my huddle I
don't get the pie in the face I
understand you want me to give you a pie
in the face right here no no no no I up
I wouldn't mind giving a pie in your
face though D that would be so funny how
about I give you one you give me
one how about that little quid do you
know see do you want to do that right
now I would look like dark as I am with
white over we're not going down that
road again I Mike Mike I got a chocolate
cream pie back there for
you I'll give if you'll take a pie I'll
take a pie we both do it right right
yeah do I'll have him make it up here in
the next 15
minutes unless you're afraid Mike you
just called me
out I'm sorry did I stutter why do I
have to come to take a pie in the face
you should all your dudes out here have
taken a you should have already taken a
did somebody just tap out I I I think I
think playmaker just listen I'm all
in how can we how can we decide who gets
no no no it's just I'll give you one you
give me one Mike I've never had a pie in
the face D I've never had a pie in the
face I I got other interviews to go do
what I look like to my face that might
be fun though it might be fun h on H on
let's let's I got another shirt to call
pull up my other shirt so I can use this
one later and and let's do it let's do
it you do it yeah let's do it all right
all right uh we need to have two pies uh
made up back there let's do it if we can
all right let's do it we'll come back
pie in the face we'll come back let's do
it this is too far Michael Michael Irvin
said that I wouldn't take a pie to the
face and I said I'd be more than happy
to would he be willing to take a pie to
the face so uh here we are with cream
pies chocolate cream pie for you
Mike uh so this is what it comes down to
it's you it's me you ready three Set
Go I just got na that's an
[Music]
explosion my
[Laughter]
goodness I don't know if you got me I
don't know if you got me
Mike I don't know if you got
me that was a tie I think that's a tie
yeah I got some sh there some weight
behind it too now weight you got me on
the
nose Mike popped me on the nose got was
all right that's the first time I've
ever got in the
face look good I look like who I look
like right now I'm not making any
comment I'm not making any
comments take a break uh well you know
what it's probably best we take a break
here and we'll come back to closeup chop
here the D Patrick Show right after this
The Dan Patrick Show weekday mornings on
audience